[Musique]
bonsoir merci d'être fidèle et auditions
publiques le rendez vous du lundi soir
le rendez vous politique auditions
publiques lcp public sénat avec le
figaro quel drôle de printemps parce
qu'en plus du cockpit dont on n'est pas
sorti voilà que le climat s'en mêle le
jeune a fait des dégâts dans les vignes
dans les cultures dans une dizaine de
régions en france et les pertes sont
importantes c'est un nouveau coup dur un
nouveau coup au moral pour les
producteurs qui ont déjà perdu beaucoup
avec la fermeture des restaurants ou des
cantines d'entreprise aujourd'hui une
première réunion de crise s'est déroulée
au ministère de l'agriculture pour faire
le point les deux parlementaires qui
vont venir débattre tout à l'heure avec
notre invité ont des questions précises
à poser est notre invité aujourd'hui
c'est jean julien parrou de damvant dit
que c est moi
bises l'agriculture et l'alimentation
merci d'être avec nous merci à vous ce
soir vous avez tenu une réunion donc
aujourd'hui au ministère de
l'agriculture
pas de décision de prise pour l'instant
sur les aides vous attendait de savoir
exactement quelle est l'ampleur des
pertes
en attendant de savoir quelle est
l'ampleur des pertes est-ce qu'il peut y
avoir des aides d'urgence qui seront
débloquées à notre objectif c'est de
mettre en place les aides au moment où
les agriculteurs en ont le plus besoin
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a eu un
événement climatique dramatique
probablement la plus grande catastrophe
agronomique de ce début du 21ème siècle
c'est à dire qu'on a eu un effet qui a
été un effet de fortes chaleurs donc la
plante s'est développé le bourgeon est
devenu fleurs est devenu petits fruits
et dans une nuit les températures ont
chuté drastiquement et c'est venu cramer
l'ensemble des dispositifs et donc ça ce
sont des pertes économiques d'abord pour
les producteurs de fruits à partir de
juin juillet qui étaient des ventes qui
n'auront donc pas lieu ensuite pour les
producteurs de vin un peu plus tard mais
également pour la grande culture et donc
les dispositifs d'être que nous sommes
en train de mettre en place sont des
dispositifs qui prennent compte des
revenus qui n'arriveront pas donc qui
seront échelonnés qui seront qui doivent
être échelonné parce que quand vous êtes
un abricotier dans la drôme votre perte
de revenus elle va apparaître dès le
mois de juin dès le mois de juillet
quand vous êtes un viticulteur dans
l'hérault ou dans le bordelais vos
pertes arriveront qu avec un an de
décalage manque il faut et c'est sa
toute la difficulté mettre en place un
dispositif qui prennent compte des
réalités de terrain
et notamment du moment vous n'aurez pas
le revenu car vous attendiez je viens de
normandie vous dites quand les
producteurs en auront besoin mais ce
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin tout de suite
d'être d'urgence alors aujourd'hui on va
mettre des en place des aides présents
pour ce moment il y aura des questions
sur le chômage partiel sur les charges
patronales sur des personnes qui avant
lé travail et qui aujourd'hui du fait de
ces cultures qui sont fortement
impactées devront être aidés donc ça
pourrait se mettre en place rapidement
fin ce seront des dispositifs qui vont
se mettre en place rapidement mais ce
que nous souhaitons c'est à la fois les
dispositifs dead mais vu l'ampleur des
dégâts mettre en place un fonds dits
exceptionnels
un fonds qui viennent compenser les
pertes de revenus
les impacts sur l'excédent brut
d'exploitation comme on dit dans le
monde agricole
et ça il faudra faire en sorte qu'il
arrive au moment où les agriculteurs en
ont besoin c'est à dire au moment où
leurs revenus n'arriveront pas dans les
caisses on ne sait pas encore combien
mais on sait que sa tâche est franc
milliards bien aujourd'hui ce que l'on
sait de manière certaine c'est que ce
sont plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'hectares je dis bien centaines de
milliers d'hectares qui ont été impactés
lourd en terme d'argent ça veut dire
donc en termes d'argent ce sera très
significatif je peux pas vous donner de
chiffres parce qu'on est en train de
faire d'une part les remontées
territoire par territoire plus de dix
régions sur 13 sont impactées et d'autre
part parce que malheureusement une
deuxième vague de froid arrive sur notre
territoire cette semaine dès ce début de
semaine et donc vont venir va venir
rajouter de la difficulté à la
difficulté mais je le redis c'est
probablement le pire événement
climatique et agronomiques que notre
pays ait connu depuis le début du 21e
rang veut aller plus loin avec ma
consoeur de lcp brigitte boucher bonsoir
gîte dans sa france et de public sénat
bonsoir steve blitz à vous de commencer
oui et je vais vous parler des
viticulteurs en particulier ils n'ont
pas le droit au régime de calamité
agricole
à quoi vont ils donc avoir droit comme
aide
et bien ce dispositif de fonds
exceptionnel qu'on est en train de
mettre en place à la demande du premier
ministre
j'étais dès vendredi auprès de
viticulteurs qui effectivement ont eu
des impacts considérables et comme vous
l'avez vous l'avez dit ne sont pas
éligibles aux calamités agricoles
pourquoi parce que leur culture est dit
assurables enfin la réalité c'est qu'il
ya
20 à 30 % des viticulteurs qui sont
assurés et donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour tous ceux qui alors juste cité et
c'est là on va mettre en place ce fonds
exceptionnel qui va venir couvrir une
partie des pertes avec des dispositifs
totalement nouveau parce que l'ampleur
du phénomène fait que nos outils dead
habituels ne sont pas adaptés et c'est
vraiment ça qu'il faut avoir en tête et
donc on va prendre et mettre en place un
dispositif totalement ça ce sera pour
les 70% restants vous le disiez ya à peu
près oui 20 30 % des agriculteurs qui
fait que tu aies viticulteurs qui sont
assurées tout simplement parce que les
assurances sont trop chers est ce que
vous demandez aux assureurs de revoir
les conditions de leur contrat leurs
tarifs
alors nous avons mobilisé très fortement
les assureurs mais aussi les banquiers
les assureurs pour qu'il se déploie avec
beaucoup de rapidité qu'il ya aucune
inertie pour venir accompagner celles et
ceux qui sont assurés mais aussi des
banquiers je pense par exemple à nos
jeunes agriculteurs qui commence dans la
vie c'est une caractéristique du monde
agricole avec énormément d'emprunt je
pense à nos viticulteurs qui dans la
période cette année ou des débouchés ont
été fermés du fait des restaurants ont
contracté beaucoup de prêts bien les
intérêts de ces prêts y court et donc
nous avons réuni ce matin également tous
les banquiers les assureurs pour nous
assurer de leur prenne plein de
mobilisation pour qu'ils prennent la
tâche de leurs assurés ou de leurs
créanciers pour devoir exonérés ils vont
devoir je crois que cette solidarité
nationale vis-à-vis de 7 ce qui nous
nourrissent dans un tel événement
exceptionnel cette solidarité nationale
elle doit avant tout venir de l'état
enfin elle doit venir aussi de celles et
ceux qui désirent les supplémentaires
aux assureurs non seulement je leur
demande mais ce matin ils ont pris
l'engagement il était lors de cette
cellule de crise que nous avons instauré
ils ont pris l'engagement d'accompagner
fortement nos agriculteurs crise donc il
va serait régulièrement exactement nous
avons d'ores et déjà acté que nous nous
réunirons à nouveau en début de semaine
prochaine pour faire le point sur
justement l'ensemble des dispositifs que
nous sommes en train de mettre en place
ça va être un suivi sur la durée au
regard de l'ampleur des dégâts une
solidarité qui va venir donc de l'état
vous l'avez dit peut-être janvier les
assureurs osé le titre peut être aussi
des régions laurent wauquiez qui
débloque 15 millions d'euros pour les
agriculteurs locaux est ce que vous
demandez aux autres présidents de région
de faire la même chose c'est à eux d'en
décider mais évidemment cette solidarité
c'est très bien je salue lorsque des
collectivités locales viennent les
appuyer et viennent accompagner nos
agriculteurs dans la région
de laurent wauquiez c'est vrai qu'il ya
des zones qui ont été incroyablement
impactés j'étais samedi avec le premier
ministre en la vallée du rhône auprès
des arboriculteurs vous savez c'est beau
abricots d'ardèche de la drôme qui ont
été incroyablement impact et il faut
voir ce que ça représente le problème du
gel c'est que c'est invisible quand vous
regardez une parcelle d'abricotiers
aujourd'hui vous avez l'impression que
les arbres ils sont toujours en fleur en
fait tous les fruits mais tous les
fruits sur certaines parcelles ont cramé
donc classer lisibilité
elles cachent l'ampleur des dégâts mais
imaginez si cela avait été un incendie
on serait en train de parler de
centaines de milliers d'hectares
incendie la même chose avec le fort sur
une année pas sûr perdre à venir c'est
la même chose c'est ça dont on parle il
me salue ces aides vont revenir aux
aides à ce que le plan de relance
qu'ovide pourra contribuer et bien à
aider un peu ses producteurs et ses
agriculteurs qui sont touchés on a déjà
à vrai dire parce que c'est un sujet
récurrent qui moi je veux en faire un
marqueur fort de mon action on a déjà
dans le cadre de france renonce une
enveloppe de 100 millions d'euros dédiés
au financement des infrastructures pour
lutter contre ces aléas du changement
climatique c'est quoi pour limiter le
gel vous mettez par exemple des grandes
pales de ventilateur pour garder l'air
le plus chaud au sol afin de réchauffer
l'air vous investissez sur un fait c'est
tour antigel sur des investissements qui
permettent de mettre un peu de chaleur
les décès de l'année et donc dès cette
année il ya des jeunes ligne de
financement de 100 millions d'euros à
destination d agrippine être augmenté
aujourd'hui à peu près 25% que cette
ligne qui a déjà fait l'objet de
demandes donc il reste des financements
dessus mais ce matin on a très
clairement vu que on pouvait améliorer
cette ligne de financement donc on le
fera pour qu'elles soient plus simples
d'utilisation notamment dans les
critères améliorés ou abonder améliorer
d'abord ici il faut abondé évidemment
qu'on l'a bondra mais aujourd'hui on a
encore plus de 75 millions d'euros 2
disponible donc on a quoi financer un
certain nombre de dispositifs
après il faut avoir en tête que cet
épisode de gel malgré des agriculteurs
qui se sont battus ça a été une
véritable bataille d'une guerre contre
le froid dans l'état des recherches
actuelles aucun des dispositifs connu ne
permettait de lutter contre le ch elle
est là c'est l'ingénieur agronome que
vous
exact et gîtes et ça montre l'ampleur du
phénomène vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
les fruits notamment les abricots ont
été touchés il y aura sans doute des
légumes également on s'attend finalement
à ce que ces produits là soit plus cher
sur les étals sur les marchés demain est
ce que c'est le consommateur qui va
payer les pots cassés pas ce qui est sûr
c'est que le consommateur aura beaucoup
moins axé cette année à des abricots à
des cerises à certains fruits que il en
a l'habitude on fait d'ailleurs très
attention parce que il ya parfois des
fraudes qui peuvent avoir lieu avec des
produits qui viennent de l'étranger qui
sont emballés en france et qui sont
estampillés france et donc les
professionnels nous ont demandé d'être
extrêmement vigilants ils ont raison
pour lutter contre quelconque qui
commande
comment vous allez payer ces des
contrôles des contrôles par l'autorité
des fraudes et donc on y sera très
vigilant mais oui il est très probable
qu'il y aura un impact sur le marché et
notamment sur le prix des produits
français sur nos étals dc7 mais il
faudra quand même peut être importé des
produits venus les tendons importe déjà
beaucoup puisqu'un fruits et légumes sur
deux dans notre pays est important ce
sera plus mais ce sera dé facto plus et
defacto la la rareté de la qualité de
nos produits sera telle que probablement
les prix s'en feront ressentir à leurs
visages c'est un état de fait
face à la difficulté à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés
voilà pour la situation d'aujourd'hui on
va parler mais d'ici là c'est tout
consommateur a un rôle à jouer parce que
évidemment venir soutenir celles et ceux
qui souffrent en privilégiant ses
produits du territoire ces produits
qu'ils soient viticole fruitiers ou que
ce soit des productions locales
c'est aussi un moyen de les soutenir
dans la parviennent à vendre ça c'est
aujourd'hui on reparle est un petit peu
d'avenir parce qu'en ce moment aussi se
discute la future politique agricole
commune la future politique agricole
commune qui doit entrer en vigueur à
partir de 2023 et on assiste à une
multiplication ces dernières semaines
des manifestations d'agriculteurs à
l'appel de la fnsea contre cette future
pac une future pac qui prévoit notamment
que les nouvelles aides seront versées
aux agriculteurs qui font des efforts
pour l'environnement concrètement
qu'est-ce qui est encore négocier parce
que tout est plié
non aujourd'hui on est en plein dans la
concertation la discussion on a encore
plusieurs semaines de concertation de
discussion ce qu'il faut bien avoir en
tête c'est que la france s'est battu
pour qu'on ait un budget ambitieux et
c'était pas gagné d'avancé
vraiment une victoire de la france au
niveau européen et donc on a 9 milliards
et demi de financement européen par an
pour le monde agricole est aujourd'hui
se joue la répartition de ce montant au
sein des filières au sein des
territoires au sein des productions
tendu et donc chacun fait entendre sa
voir évidemment en disant que qu'est ce
qui est négocié gaz est bien et ce qui
est négociable c'est absolument tous les
critères de la politique agricole
commune et dieu sait qu'il en a pas ce
qu'est la politique agricole commune
c'est un tout alors c'est extrêmement
technique mais c'est énormément de
dispositifs qui sont aujourd'hui un
briquet les uns dans les autres et donc
avec les filières végétales animales
on est en discussion pour savoir comment
bien positionné des critères prendre
compte ce qui les spécificités des
territoires notamment qui ferrer cette
fois les agriculteurs sur les échos
régime c est justement lié à
l'environnement
c est qu au régime c'est non négociable
ils s'appliqueront le principe oui
mathon le diable se cache dans les
détails c'est le principe mais c'était
largement négociable mais exactement
mais ce qu'il faut vraiment avoir en
tête parce que vous savez souvent moi
j'entends ce petit discours en disant
que la transition agro écologique serait
pas suffisant pour que nos auditeurs
contre comprennent bien c'est quoi les
qu'au régime ça veut dire qu'on va dire
aux agriculteurs
on prend environ 25% de votre salaire on
vous enlève ses 25 % de votre salaire et
on ne voulait redonne que si vous mettez
en place des transitions agro
écologiques c'est ça la réalité quelle
profession quelle profession voit une
telle transformation passer dans le
monde agricole donc quand d'autres
disent que ça va pas assez vite passé
loin je les amène à méditer sur cette
situation et les électeurs vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est ce qui nous
nourrissent alors comme vous êtes aussi
ministre de l'alimentation brigitte on
va aller sur ce sujet oui parce qu on se
souvient que vous avez été assez
virulent pour dénoncer les menus sans
viande décidée par le maire écologiste
grégory dossier dans les cantines
scolaires de lyon dans le projet de loi
climat il est prévu une expérimentation
du même genre avec une alternative
végétarienne quotidienne dans les
communes dans les cantines pour les
communes qui le souhaitent
finalement au bout du compte est-ce que
l'étape d'après c'est pas le menu
végétarien pour tous non moi je pense
que c'est le choix le voyez ce que vous
avez dit dans votre présentation tous
les maux était important dans le projet
de loi est discutée aujourd'hui le choix
le choix donné moi dans notre république
je suis pour le choix les choses à lyon
non non non non non lannion c'était
on aime on imposait on imposait de ne
pas avoir jamais aucun jour de la
semaine de viande donc on ne laisse pas
le choix
à partir du moment où on laisse le choix
il ya aucun problème moi je ne suis
personne pour édicter un régime
alimentaire
votre régime alimentaire ne me
concernent que peut par contre dans ce
choix dans la république dans la vie
engagée exactement dans la république il
faut laisser le choix premièrement et
deuxièmement moi je suis le garant de
l'équilibré alimentaire et donc mon
combat c'est la qualité aujourd'hui en
aux cantines mon combat c'est la qualité
de la vie équilibre alimentaire et les
producteurs de jouer parce que en fait
les producteurs de viande oeufs sont
inquiets y aura quand même moins de
viande dans les cantines donc ils vont
enregistrer des pertes
est-ce que vous ai su mais finalement de
laisser cris jean le gros problème il
est quoi aujourd'hui 60% de la viande
dans nos cantines
elle est importée il est là le sujet et
donc moi mon combat c'est pas d'imposer
un régime alimentaire à qui que ce soit
c'est de faire en sorte que la viande de
qualité de nos territoires
elle se retrouve beaucoup moins borné de
viande par exemple dans la loi et galim
il ya dans la loi climat par pardon il
ya une disposition qui est très
importante et j'espère que des
parlementaires vont la voter
et moi je la soutiendrai fortement il
est vous savez aujourd'hui dit que dans
la restauration collective publique
il faut qu'il ait au moins 50 % de
produits de cali et ben cet objectif là
on va l'étendre à toute la restauration
privée
notre combat c'est la qualité mon combat
dans les cantines c'est la qualité bio
vous voulez dormir c'est là où il faut
avancer ce que vous lire c'est que les
producteurs français de viande n'y
perdront pas forcément c'est les
importations qui seront moins nombreux
c'est ça l'objectif
ces objectifs mais va y arriver c'est ce
sur quoi on discute en ce moment avec
les parlementaires parce que vraiment
faut avoir en tête notre agriculture sa
singularité ce qui fait son adn c'est la
qualité et donc si on veut de la qualité
fois d'abord accepté de payer le prix et
deuxièmement la promouvoir partout alors
vraiment dans les cantines on va parler
du lait maintenance de lactalis plus
précises acte de nitromed
les frères est supprimé vous le savez
l'origine du lait sur l'étiquetage de
ces produits produits à ce que vous n'y
serez de l'agriculture vous demander le
retour de cet étiquetage et si oui
comment vous comptez vous y prenez
d'abord
ce qui s'est passé c'est que lactalis a
déposé un recours devant la cour de
justice de l'union européenne
c'est la cour de justice de l'union
européenne cette juridiction là qui a
pris une position qui conduit à cette
situation un scandale pour vous mais ces
scandales aucune entreprise française un
fleuron industriel puisse aller devant
la cour de justice européenne demandé à
ce que l'origine des produits ne soient
plus indiquées sur les briques de lait
les bras m'en tombent
c'est absolument aberrant et c'est
pourtant ce à la situation à laquelle on
est confronté donc on fait quoi rester
la décision juste et fall steve le point
c'est que le politique n'est pas au
dessus des décisions de justice donc le
politique doit appliquer et l'europe
s'impose deux sujets qu'il nous faut
faire
le premier sujet c'est d'avoir la
bataille au niveau européen et c'est ce
que je mène en tant que ministre de
l'agriculture donc conseil européen pour
faire bouger les lignes sur cette
origine premier point
deuxième point il ya des choses sur
lequel on peut faire au niveau français
par exemple
à défaut de mettre l'origine france -
que ce soit l'origine union européenne
ça on peut le faire on est en train de
modifier les textes pour le faire et
troisième élément on parle du lait mais
il ya un autre sujet très important on
en parle est un instant sur la viande et
s'assure la viande d'ici l'été je vous
annonce on prendra un décret qui
imposera l'origine de la viande partout
dans la restauration le régime française
lorie l'origine d'où vient votre viande
aux joies que quelle que soit l'origine
mais vous prenez un poulet aujourd'hui
dans la restauration hors domicile
une immense majorité des poulets qui
sont consommés ça vient d'ukraine ou de
brésil et ça il faudra que ce soit écrit
il faut que ce soit écrit pour le
consommateur un poulet bryzhina ou
ukrainiens j'ai rien contre le brésil je
voulais brezina ukrainien ça n'est en
rien la même qualité nutritionnelle
qu'un poulet français et le consommateur
il doit en être informé ça veut dire que
vous quand vous serez parents d'élèves
vous arriverez dans une cantine et si
demain vous vous apercevez que le
poulain les brésiliens ou le poulet il
est brésilien oui craignent un je pense
que votre comportement permettra aussi
un certain changement de pratique pour
les cantines et des restaurants à
l'origine cantines restaurants
restauration est de réussir mérite
revient à la loi et galim avec les
négociations annuelles qui se sont
achevés il ya peu de temps entre donc
les agriculteurs les éleveurs et
grande distribution avec un nouveau
constat d'échec
c'est ce que disent en tout cas les
agriculteurs et les éleveurs et vous
n'excluez pas il me semble une nouvelle
loi aujourd'hui quand elles pourraient
avoir lieu et quand elle pourrait être
votée moi j'y suis favorable à cette
nouvelle loi je pense qu'elle galim
c'était nécessaire mais pas suffisant ça
a été un profond changement d'état
d'esprit
mais ça ne va pas assez loin aujourd'hui
et donc on continue à avoir la même
guerre des prix confère tout ce qu'on
vient de se dire la guerre des prix
c'est antinomique avec la qualité de
notre agriculture
il faut avoir le courage politique de
dire que si on veut une agriculture
française qui n'agrée culture de police
de qualité il faut avoir le courage de
dire que cette agriculture de qualité
elle doit être rémunéré des sciences et
qui va payer
c'est la grande émotion est ce que celle
ci c'est d'abord une juste répartition
entre agriculteurs industriels et grande
distribution et après le consommateur la
question s'était aussi s'il n'exclut pas
une nouvelle loi les plombs il faut
qu'il est ce qu'elle est prête il ya un
certain nombre de parlementaires
notamment grégory besson moreau qui vont
qu'il va déposer par dans les prochains
jours une proposition de loi qui me
paraît les pleinement dans ce sens si
faso du par le gouvernement on est en
train de discuter mais inutile de vous
dire qu'on a beaucoup travaillé avec lui
pour que ça aille dans ce sens le sens
des recommandations du rapport de serge
papin premièrement et deuxièmement pour
être très précis dans ma réponse
si on veut que cela ait un effet avant
les prochaines négociations commerciales
en octobre il faut que les débats
parlementaires puissent débuter avant
l'été
donc on est dans un cadre parlementaire
un rêve à lévis landrier très serré mais
pour moi c'est un terreau yeux la
souveraineté de notre agriculture elle
passe par cette prime une dernière et
son logis depuis de steve
oui les taxes américaines sur à les vins
et spiritueux français ont été suspendu
début mars par l'administration maiden
et ce pour quatre mois
est-ce que vous avez bon espoir qu'elle
soit définitivement levé on y travaille
j'étais encore il ya dix jours avec mon
homologue américain en réunion pour
justement faire en sorte que ce
moratoire de quatre mois vous avez
raison puisse se transformer dans une
décision pérenne
vous serez camp d'en avant les quatre
mois donc maintenant avant dans deux
mois et demi ils les discussions se
poursuivent se poursuivre par don à mon
niveau à celui de bruno le maire
également et des gens il croisait les
doigts vous croisez les doigts pour
l'instant
on a bon espoir d'y arriver mais on
maintient ses diplomates hic c'est
d'autant plus important dans la période
avec ce que les viticulteurs viennent de
subir on a perdu deux tiers de nos
agriculteurs en 30 ans est ce que c'est
une c'est un métier d'avenir encore
aujourd'hui oui profondément moi je le
crois sinon je me lèverai pas tous les
matins je mange et je suis ingénieur
agronome j'ai fait j'ai cette même
passion agricole mais le problème
justement c'est dans notre pays on se
repose sur la passion sur la passion
agricole sur la passion d'être de deux
mois je qualifie les agriculteurs
d'entrepreneurs du vivant qui
nourrissent le peuple et tous les mots
sont importants
ils nourrissent le peuple et ses scènes
passion c'est nourrir le peuple cette
noble mission
mais ce sont des entrepreneurs du vivant
n'y a rien de plus difficile que de
travailler avec le vivant on vient de le
voir dans ces épisodes de gênes et ce
sont des entrepreneurs
donc ils doivent vivre de leur travail
et de vrd ils doivent être rémunérés et
c'est là tout le combat que je mène sur
et galim et c'est parce que la passion
ne peut pas tout et la rémunération est
essentielle ainsi brigitte et merci
steve merci à vous la vaccination contre
le coc vidal était tendue depuis
aujourd'hui aux plus de 55 ans alors la
question c'est de savoir s'il faudrait
l'étendre ou là réservé à certaines
professions s'il faudrait organiser ça
vous allez entendre laurent berger
secrétaire général de la cgt qui pensent
ça lui justement je crois qu'il faut que
tous ceux et toutes celles qui sont au
présentiel qu'ils le sont depuis
maintenant plus d'un an puissent accéder
à la vaccination le plus rapidement
possible a évidemment et qui sont de
stock tout ça c'est pas mon sujet mais
oui tous ceux qui sont le plus exposées
d'accéder à la vaccination sur le lieu
de travail si c'est possible par le
biais des services de santé au travail
c'est à dire la médecine du travail qui
commence à s'organiser je crois qu'il
faut accélérer là dessus mais c'est une
demande tout à fait légitime et moi je
là je la soutiens ce que dit laurent
berger qui est ce qu'il faudrait
vacciner en priorité tous ceux qui
doivent venir travailler sur ce site je
pense notamment aux abattoirs parce que
vous souvenez que c'était là qu'il y
avait eu les premiers 4 qu'ovide est ce
que vous seriez favorable justement à ce
qu'il y ait en priorité les salariés des
abattoirs
cette décision fait de manière générale
ce que dit laurent berger c'est que il
faut vacciner le plus vite possible et
notamment toutes celles et ceux qui sont
au front il a fondamentalement raison la
question derrière tout ça c'est que
cette stratégie vaccinale
elle dépend des doses de vaccin et donc
la priorité des priorités c'est
d'augmenter les doses de vaccin pour
pouvoir
élargir les personnes qu'on va vacciner
c'est aussi c'est si on peut élargir
escaut ça veut pas dire forcément pour
tout le monde de toute façon rang après
après le les publics vaccinez vous avez
vu on a eu des approches qui étaient des
approches médicales pour vacciner en
priorité toutes celles et ceux qui ont
des facteurs de comorbidité qui sont
fragiles qui ont la plus grosse
probabilité de se retrouver en
réanimation et donc c'est cette approche
là il ya tout un conseil scientifique
un conseil éthique aussi qui se réunit
sur les ordres de vaccination je déteste
ce terme et c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelle et je crois que ce processus là
doivent y a pas de raison pour vous que
les salariés des abattoirs pas savoir
les autres tous à dépendre d'une petite
question est très difficile parce que
tout ça ne dépend du nombre de doses
aujourd'hui notre priorité c'est
d'augmenter les doses d'augmenter les
vaccins et pouvoir vacciner toutes
celles et ceux qui en ont besoin
il ya d'autres priorités qui vont
arriver ses priorités politiques vont en
parler avec yves thréard bonfoh rives
on sent qu'ils résistent au figaro
directeur reçoit rien normandie alors il
ya un grand débat qui agite le milieu
politique actuellement et les élus c'est
de savoir si les élections régionales
auront lieu ou pas les 13 et 20 juin
certains comme monsieur françois bayrou
et d'autres disent banon il faudrait
mieux qu'elle ait lieu après et richard
est ce qu'on doit richard fera notamment
le président de l'assemblée nationale
est ce que ces élections qui ont déjà
été reportés d'ailleurs du mois de mars
au mois de juin doivent être encore être
reporté après l'été je crois qu'on est
tous d'accord pour dire qu'il faut
qu'elles se tiennent le plus vite
possible une fois qu'on a dit ça faut
sortir des postures
il faut dire comment on fait pour
s'assurer qu'elle se passe et qu'elle se
passe dans les meilleures conditions
vous avez vu le conseil scientifique a
fait des recommandations des
recommandations sanitaires très précise
et vous agresser le choix aussi
et ce choix c'est un choix démocratique
ça vous aura pas échappé à la fin ce
choix relève des parlementaires qui
doivent voter sur ces dates des musiques
l'arrogance étatique
oui enfin s'il ya un lien il ya un choix
évidemment démocratique et c'est pour ça
que le président de la république et le
premier ministre ont fait cette
consultation de l'ensemble des nerfs ces
derniers jours qui a fait beaucoup de
bruit
moi je crois je peux pas vous cacher mon
étonnement quand je vois
qu'un certain nombre de responsables
politiques s'étonnent que le
gouvernement consulte les maires ils en
oublient ce que ceux qui juridiquement
organiser les élections ce soit et vous
savez quoi je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce qu'il ya énormément d'observateurs
qui se disent mais le pouvoir en place
le pouvoir exécutif a peur de ces
élections qui s'annoncent pas très bonne
pour lui et il se dit bah évidemment il
brandit la peur du virus mais en fait la
vraie peur c'est la vraie peur d'une
déroute électorale de là mais vous voyez
là vous voyez la fragilité de cet
argument on aurait peur en juin et on
n'aurait pas peur en octobre
c'est pour ça que ça peut être assez
bizarre ça n'a aucun sens ça n'a aucun
sens ça n'est pas à quelconque finalité
politique que ces élections régionales
lors date est décidé c'est simplement de
faire en sorte que la démocratie ne soit
pas emprisonner dans la crise sanitaire
que la démocratie puisse s'exprimer
mais bon dieu on nous ferait le même
reproche si on n'avait pas consulté les
maires cela la réalité un crédit
d'heures au passage ce qui est ce qui
organise les élections dans notre pays
ce sont les nerfs c'est quand même bien
normal d'aller les consultants les
pauvres ils sont pas conservées enfin
ils sont concernés par l'organisation
il s'agit des élections régionales et
des élections et ses outils signa la fin
cette news qui signe à la fin pour dire
on organise c'est possible c'est pas
possible
donc c'est bien normal que ce
gouvernement les consignes je comprends
que vous vous êtes plutôt pour qu'elles
se tiennent les bases moi j'ai l'argent
je suis pour qu'elles se tiennent le
plus vite possible mais je suis pour
qu'elles ce que cela se fasse dans des
conditions et pays bas l'ont très bien
fait en édition ce qui des surveillants
des histoires sur les trottoirs par
exemple cette possible mais le conseil
scientifique a fait beaucoup de
recommandations
alors vous êtes un des piliers de la
macro ni si vous me permettez cette
expression
vous avez joué un rôle capital dans
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
on sent là que l approche de l'élection
présidentielle de 2022
il y a beaucoup de deux ans qui se
réclament de la majorité présidentielle
qui sont proches du président de la
république monsieur clément bonnefis
ministre de l'europe vous même monsieur
dupont moretti qui est bien se disent
ben moi je voudrais jouer un rôle en
2020 et je voudrais
le porte parole en fête de la parole
présidentielle
est ce que vous voulez jouer le rôle que
vous avez joué en 2010 est joué le même
rôle pour l'élection présidentielle pas
moi je crois beaucoup dans le projet qui
est le nôtre je crois beaucoup dans dans
le fait que aujourd'hui on le voit bien
d'ailleurs on sent une certaine gêne à
droite et à gauche on la sent cette gen
regard des différentes déclarations de
xavier bertrand
le summum de cela étant son interview de
ce matin dans les échos ou xavier
bertrand appelle à la diminution des
impôts de production c'est précisément
ce que ce gouvernement a fait quatre
affaires et peut-être que demain
d'ailleurs le même va demander le
dégrèvement de la taxe d'habitation
peut-être ça ne m'étonnerai même plus
mais vous savez pourquoi il ya cette
gêne à droite et à gauche c'est
probablement et c'est ça le projet
présidentiel
c'est qu'on a fait et à droite et à
gauche ce que ses responsables
politiques avait dit qu'il ferait sans
jamais le faire
vous prenez les impôts de production
jean neige et à droite les impôts de
production j'en ai parlé la réforme du
travail nous l'avons fait la réforme de
la sncf
nous vous l'avons fait vous prenez à
gauche l'école jamais aucun gouvernement
n'aura autant fait est ce que vous
demandez icd une espèce de compétition
l'a donc cette gêne là elle et elle est
palpable mais moi je pense que ça veut
dire qu'on est dans le vrai avec le
projet présidentiel et je souhaite que
l'on puisse continuer à le mener et je
souhaiterais est-ce que vous êtres pour
c'est ce que vous c'est vous qui serez
je dirais le coordinateur de tout
aujourd'hui moi je suis un match entre
ministres d'agriculture et vous savez vu
le nombre de dossiers que j'ai à gérer
en ce moment cette tâche me suffit
amplement par contre à titre personnel
si le président de la république vous
présente sa candidature
évidemment que je me battrai avec
énormément de détermination un jury les
arguments de force sur quel projet parce
que vous parlez d'un projet mais le
projet s'est un petit peu perdues je
dirais dans les limbes du gros navires
uceda crise sanitaire
c'était un projet qui était
d'émancipation individuelle
pour résumer est-ce que tout a pas été
complètement transformée avec cette
crise qui a vu que nos services publics
étaient parfois défaillant qui a vu
quand on croulait sous une bureaucratie
impotente est-ce qu'il faut pas revoir
un petit peu est-ce que ce procès va pas
être complètement bouleversée par
rapport aux promesses
évidemment 2022 sera très différente
2017 c'est une évidence et évidemment la
crise sanitaire va impliquer de tirer
des enseignements sur le système de
santé du système socio de protection des
systèmes d'organisation en tant que
crise après il ya des fondamentaux qui
restent et qui perdure le travail
l'écologie l'émancipation individuelle
la lutte contre les inégalités de la
maîtrise de son destin individuel
retrouvez également la maîtrise de son
destin collectif
autant de choses qui font l'adn d'autres
et vous avez payé la sécurité non mais
les avait séparés l'insécurité c'est là
aussi typique de cette gêne qu'on peut
ressentir chez nos opposants d'accord
les mêmes qui aujourd'hui sont en fait
river les yeux rivés sur les élections
là où et ça n'est pas botter en touche
que de le dire c'est la réalité nous on
n'a pas les yeux rivés sur l'élection on
a des yeux rivés sur la vaccination
c'est ça notre priorité absolue du
moment mais les mêmes sur l'insécurité
c'est quand même énorme ils nous font
des critiques sur notre politique
sécuritaire là on est plus dix mille
postes de policiers de jandin alors que
eux mêmes
on avait supprimé 10 mille et donc ça
aussi ce sera l'un des sujets évident de
la conjoncture étaient en 2017 il y
avait eu un deuxième tour qui opposait
madame le pen à monsieur vaqueront est
ce que quelque chose pourrait empêcher
ou quelqu'un pourrait empêcher que ce
match entre cette femme et cet homme
soit se reproduise en 2022 en tout cas
moi je suis pas du tout de ceux qui
considèrent que par fatalité madame le
pen serait et l'extrême droite serait
forcément second tour si je me souviens
très bien des monsieur et mathieu macro
non plus d'ailleurs
oui mais enfin mon combat il mon combat
il est il est contre le front national
depuis toujours depuis mon engagement
politique
moi je suis et d'ailleurs je je
la macro nisme c'est pas un projet de
rempart c'est un projet d'espoir
d'émancipation de la vente de
transformation mais vous savez en 2017
le débat c'était de se dire madame le
pen elle sera en tête le soir du premier
tour et on était à l'époque les seuls à
dire non non on va se battre
bon ben moi mon engagement politique il
est de se battre contre le froid mais
vous dites que ce n'est pas une fatalité
qu'elle soit au second tour mais c'est
pas une fatalité que de se dire de toute
manière le front national il est là le
front national non le front national il
sera là tant que les problèmes de notre
pays
perdure on est donc notre responsabilité
c'est de lutter contre ces problèmes
mais regardez moi je fais pas vrai dans
dans je regarde mes opposants politiques
du front national vous avez peut-être vu
cette séquence qui est à nouveau
incroyable on a beaucoup parlé des
manquements de l'incompétence de madame
le pen de son de sa banalisation en fait
elle veut simplement accéder au pouvoir
pour accéder au pouvoir pas pour exercer
des politiques nouvelles
regardez l'imprécision de l'un de ses
porte parole hier sur une chaîne
concurrente
quand il évoque son programme aux
régionales jordan bardella qu'il même
incapable de citer le nombre de gares en
ile de france alors que c'est un des
piliers de son proviseur l'aprécial
cette incompétence cette banalisation
ce manque de vision moi c'est ce que je
combats depuis toujours derrière cette
fracture est ce qu'il représente et qui
incarne le front national est alors face
à l monsieur mâcon qui n'est pas non
plus assurés d'être deuxièmes tours
est ce que le en même temps qui a été
répété à l'envi est quelque chose qui
peut durer et qui peut je dirais résisté
à la tempête
oui moi je le pense mais plus que du en
même temps ce fameux libéré protéger
unir je pense que c'est ça le libérer ce
que j'évoquais dans toutes ses récents
que la droite aurait rêvé de faire
qu'elle n'a jamais fait sur le travail
sur la sncf sur la lutte contre les
statuts le protéger c'est toutes ces
réformes que la gauche n'a pas fait et
qu'on a fait sur l'école sur l'égalité
ce qu'on fait on sert à manger la droite
sont mortes
c'est je ne sais pas mais en tout cas je
préfèrerais avoir une gauche et une
droite plutôt qu'un front national comme
adversaire non non je ne dirais jamais
ça sait jamais ça
ah mais ça parce que je préfère des
partis républicain démocratique que du
front national toujours et le unir je
pense que le moment de sortie de cette
crise de l'aco vide ça va être le moment
où justement il va falloir faire nation
il va falloir bien en force au
rassemblement national n'est pas un
parti républicain
à l'évidence non par son histoire par
part ça ça vous monte de division et
encore une fois je crois ce qu'il faut
voir beaucoup à parler de la
banalisation de madame le pen mais je
pense que plus qu'une banalisation
en fait elle s'avère être une
responsable politique comme les français
ne supportent plus les responsables
politiques c'est à dire une seule
finalité accéder au pouvoir n'ont pas
exercé le pouvoir pour unifier protéger
libérer et c'est ça que moi je porte
merci yves merci vent six mois par une
jeune consoeur yves morgan large sais
pas si vous la connaissez les
journalistes à radio kreiz breiz en
bretagne radios associatives il joue
liberté mais j'ai des origines bretonnes
j'aurais dû me douter elle a été
plusieurs fois menacée elle a vu une
roue de sa voiture déboulonner elle est
connue dans la région pour ses enquêtes
sur ce qu'elle appelle l'agrobusiness
l'industrie agroalimentaire ces dérives
on connaît la surproduction la pollution
les algues vertes en bretagne sont des
sujets sensibles là bas une
manifestation de soutien était organisée
la semaine dernière elle a reçu aussi le
soutien de reporters sans frontières
est ce que cette consoeur as aussi votre
soutien à l'évidence oui je n'ai aucun
élément sur sur l' enquête en cours mais
mais dans une république il n'y a ni
intimidation ni menaces et encore moins
mise en danger d'autrui donc quelles que
soient les convictions des uns et des
autres
ces principes républicains dont cali à
l'évidence oui sauf que elle est accusée
donc de faire de la grille bashing c'est
un mot qui était arrivé il ya quelques
années on va dire est ce qu'il est
possible de critiquer le modèle
industriel agricole
il est possible de le faire il faut le
combattre
quand on n'est pas d'accord dans le
combat d'idées je vais vous donner un
exemple qui moi m'a beaucoup marqué
salut dans notre pays on parle beaucoup
du modèle d'élevage
il ya quelques jours quelques semaines
il ya eu un reportage de yann arthus
bertrand qui s'appelle legacy dans ce
reportage on a montré des élevages des
élevages de truies avec des immeubles
les étages des élevages de vaches
laitières avec des dizaines de milliers
les usines il s'avère que ce reportage
ne mentionnait aucunement le fait que
ces élevages n'existait pas en france
mais existe et à l'international en asie
et aux etats unis d'amérique et moi ce
que je dis il faut que chacun en ait
conscience c'est que notre modèle
d'élevage là où sur les truies c'est par
exemple 150 en moyenne versus ces
immeubles de 13 étages dès lors qu'on va
le dénigrer dès lors qu'on va le
combattre ce que certains certains
peuvent faire de manière démocratique
encore une fois dès lors qu'on va le
combattre
quelle est la conclusion tout ça c'est
qu'on a on augmente les importations et
donc on favorise précisément les
élevages qui ne respectent pas nos
modèles de territoire julien normande il
est temps maintenant d'accueillir les
deux parlementaires qui vont débattre
avec vous
deux parlementaires que je vous présente
jean marie sermier
et juste à ses côtés jean claude tissot
j'ai présenté un parrain jean marie
sermier bonsoir d'abord bonsoir vous
êtes député les républicains du jura
vous êtes vice président de la
commission spéciale sur le climat à
l'assemblée et au passage je signale que
monsieur servier vignerons et à ses
côtés donc jean claude tissot bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes sénateur ps de la
loire secrétaire du sénat et monsieur a
été agriculteur éleveur de moutons tout
à fait de la confédération paysanne à
son époque
voilà tout est dit et comme on commence
toujours par ordre alphabétique sait
mais ils ont des points communs à
débattre avec vous c'est donc jean marie
sermier qui va poser la première
question concernant le gel parce que
vous êtes dans une région viticole le
jura les bons vins du jura ça va être
dur
écoutez effectivement monsieur le
ministre bonsoir nous avons vécu une
semaine catastrophique pour
l'agriculture française vous évoquez
avec plaisir les vins du jura mais ça
n'est pas que les vins du jura alors
effectivement le vignoble du jura a été
touché quelques fois même à 100% dans le
sud du vignoble mais les agriculteurs
ont beaucoup perdu
ils ont perdu non seulement leur outil
de travail ils ont perdu ils ont perdu
leur chiffre d'affaires de l'année pour
certains c'est pas le revenu de l'année
c'est le chiffre d'affaires complet qui
s'est écroulé avec l'impossibilité
d'arrêter certaines charges parce qu'il
va falloir continuer à travailler
que ce soit dans l'arboriculture que ce
soit la viticulture que ce soit les
betteraviers qui devront se met à
nouveau le remettra donc comment
envisagez vous monsieur le ministre de
pouvoir répondre à cette question il ya
une question financière il ya une
question dans le long terme
et puis il ya quand même une question
psychologique parce que moi j'ai vu des
agriculteurs une cinquantaine d'années
pleurait dans leurs vignes et ça c'est
intolérable
je vais commencer pour ça même si le
député j'ai d'abord commencé par le
troisième point parce que jean marie
sermier a tout à fait raison c'est le la
détresse aller total et donc on a
mobilisé évidemment tous les acteurs que
soient les chambres d'agriculture que
soient les acteurs de la mutualité
sociale agricole tous ces acteurs de la
solidarité et elle existe cette
solidarité dans le monde paysan elle est
très forte pour accompagner donc ça
on fait évidemment tout ce qu'on peut là
dessus le deuxième élément évoqué par
monsieur le député c'est la question des
indemnisations à court terme les
mécanismes aujourd'hui existants de
gestion de crise
ils sont pas mariés ils sont pas à la
hauteur de la crise qu'on a vécu donc le
premier ministre m'a demandé de mettre
en place un fonds d aide exceptionnelle
je réunissais notamment les
représentants de la viticulture ce matin
pour déterminer justement comment faire
sachant qu'en plus que dans la
viticulture comparé à l'arboriculture
cdz qu'on va devoir imaginer sur un
temps le nom parce que c'est les
récoltes de l'année prochaine donc les
revenus des et pas que le chiffre
d'affaires par dont le chiffre
d'affaires est pas que le revenu de
l'année prochaine et enfin vous poser
une question
ça fait 15 ans 20 ans qu'on tourne
autour du pot qui est la question de
manière générale de cette assurance
récolte
en fait aujourd'hui on a un système
assurantiel qui marchent pas
suffisamment mais je vous jure c'est pas
parce que les électeurs ne s'assure pas
ça nous est ce qu'il faut le rendre
obligatoire ce système d'assurance et
une vraie question se disant aujourd'hui
sous contrôle du député par exemple dans
la viticulture vous avez moins de 30%
des gens qui sont assurés et donc
certains disent si on repasse de 30 % à
100 %
on va faire une mutualisation des
risques comme on dit et donc ça va
rendre vous vous seriez pour
l'obligation d'assurer en fait j'ai
beaucoup travaillé dessus et en fait ça
ne change rien c'est à dire que les
grandes pour cent sont déjà
représentatif et donc la question qui
nous est posée c'est d'admettre que le
risque climatique aujourd'hui n'est plus
assurables par des assureurs et quand
vous prenez le parallélisme regardez
vous monsieur le tvg pas si vous avez
une voiture
oui mais votre assurance de voiture elle
est fonction de votre comportement au
volant ces dernières années c'est bien
normal pour un agrément bonus pour un
agriculteur une influence elle est
fonction du temps qu'il a fait les cinq
dernières années qui s'est dégradée et
donc moi je pense qu'il faut inventer un
nouveau modèle fondé sur une solidarité
nationale et pas que uniquement aux
mains des agriculteurs alors
complètement zappé après lice est à
prévoir que les acteurs valises parce
que aujourd'hui je ne critique pas les
assureurs et notamment un certain nombre
d'assureurs qui ont l'habitude
d'accompagner l'agriculture française on
sait aujourd'hui qu'ils le sont que d'un
rapport cotisations sur susurre
déboursement qui est extrêmement négatif
donc aujourd'hui les assureurs
ne souhaite plus assurer les
agriculteurs en leur disant mais vous
avez trop de risques et on a bien
aujourd'hui un réchauffement climatique
qui entraîne un certain nombre de
méfaits et le gel mais il ya aussi les
catastrophes d'été avec avec les
problèmes de sécheresse et donc il est
absolument impératif d'avoir une
solidarité nationale si on veut avoir
demain des personnes qui créent notre
alimentation je partage amplement mais
c'est la première fois qu'on pose le
débat en ces termes c'est à dire qu'on
arrête de croire qu'on peut trouver une
solution uniquement dans le monde
agricole
c'est pas vrai si on veut avoir un
système pérenne je pense qu'il faut en
appeler une solidarité nationale et en
fin de compte le changement climatique
il est de la responsabilité de nous tous
mais c'est qu'on sait qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire une taxe spéciale va pas
forcément une taxe mais est ce que est
ce que demain le budget national
tous à travers la politique agricole
commune ou qui finance déjà une partie
mais surtout le budget national est ce
que si on veut vraiment avoir un système
pérenne
on ne devrait pas se dire il faut que ce
budget soit aussi orientés pour mettre
en place un système assurantiel qui
repose sur une contribution de l'état
ce temps ne fait pas le cas on dit
d'ailleurs une partie est elle partie
assurance voilà on fait quoi quand ça
voulait dire exactement on fait croire
aux agriculteurs qui peuvent s'assuré
eux mêmes sauf que jean sauf que
l'agriculteur aujourd'hui n'en a pas les
moyens face à un risque qui est de plus
en plus fort et dont son comportement
des dirigeants non plus être concret si
un agriculteur mettait 50 euros par
exemple pour s'assurer l'état mettrait
autant par exactement et aujourd'hui on
le fait un peu avait à travers la
politique agricole commune mais
assurément de manière non suffisante
mais c'est des choix démocratiques très
important parce que c'est beaucoup
d'argent du budget national faut-il le
faire mais justement les aides aux
agriculteurs jean claude tissot c'est là
dessus que vous voulez aller d'accord
monsieur ministre bonsoir femme chez moi
j'ai eu mes questions seront très précis
je vais pas trop gourmand avec ce que
vient de dire mon collègue mais la
question qu'il faut se poser aujourd'hui
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a constaté
dans mon département et mais les
départements voisins la loire le rhône
la drôme l'ardèche ont souffert de façon
catastrophique du gel mais la question
qu'il faut se poser peut-être c'est
pourquoi c'est aussi catastrophique pour
les arboriculteurs les viticulteurs les
paysans en fait le jeune ça peut relever
le nez prochaine ch de l'année dernière
en jura ça fait trois ans que qui
subissent le gel c'est en fait la raison
pour laquelle c'est aussi catastrophique
c'est parce que
deux semaines auparavant on avait 28 32
exactement et ses 28 30 degrés ont
déclenché la végétation les bourgeons
sont sortis même les feuilles etc etc
et là ça a été fatale au premier coup de
gel donc si on prend pas et vous l'avez
abordé tout à l'heure si on prend pas la
problématique à bras le corps
et moi je vous interpelle directement
dans le cadre du plan de relance
est ce que on ne pourrait pas imaginer
plutôt que de financer des tracteurs et
de la ferraille on pourrait pas imaginer
un grand prendre grand plan de relance
agricole basé sur la recherche la
recherche fondamentale la recherche
appliquée je sais que vous allez me dire
il ya quelques points qui sont inscrits
mais loin il me semble quand même loin
de dole de l'enjeu au vu des
catastrophes qui ont entraîné vous avez
raison et vous verrez on a des points
d'accord et des points de désaccord
chaussures alors de l'accord les
désaccords dans les points d'accord vous
avez raison il faut et je vous reconnais
là mais mais mais le plan de relance
n'est pas du financement de ferraille le
le plan de relance par exemple
j'évoquais tout à l'heure on a 100
millions d'euros pour financer les
acquis des équipements de lutte contre
les aléas du changement climatique les
gays d'ailleurs elle et dont des tours
antigel cette affaire ait non mais c'est
très utile mais mekhak de là-haut noter
que cet arrêt par mon propos dans ce bal
de ferrage parlais dans mon tracteur ne
mâchant raconté je parle pas d'éléments
qui permettent de combattre de jazz et
d'ailleurs dans sa moi j'ai voulu en
plus qu'on ait une poche de 15 millions
d'euros dans la recherche de matériel
parce que que le comme je le disais tout
à l'heure les tours antigel qui évoque
monsieur le député en fait même elles
n'ont pas marché on sait par exemple un
abricotier à -0 5 c'est foutu sur les
docks à la neige en plus en plus et donc
il faut vous avez raison faire cette
recherche donc leurs recherches dans le
machinisme moi je fais à fond pour après
lens là on est d'accord là on serait en
désaccord par exemple sur la sécheresse
moi je suis aussi fervent défenseur des
recherche variétale
si on appelle les nouvelles nbt
aujourd'hui moi j'ai la nouvelle variété
de nuances et en fait c'est tout un
débat et sur lesquels on est en
opposition c'est aujourd'hui la
recherche variétale et c'est l'une des
grandes heures de l'agronomie
mais c'est quoi il ya dix mille ans on
faisait de la sélection de
lang pour avoir la plante la plus
productive productive mais surtout
résister talentueux au possible il ya
dix mille ans le faisait au 19e siècle
on a commencéà l'industrialiser et
aujourd'hui on en est à des nouvelles
technologies qui permettent d'accélérer
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que dans
un laboratoire
on arrive à découvrir de manière
accélérée des plans qui probablement
serait apparue dans 10 15 cents en un
endroit du globe sans qu'on arrive à
l'identifier et donc on le fait en
laboratoire et certains considèrent que
ces technologies relève des ogm ce que
je réfute c'est totalement faux à la
fois sur le fond et la forme et au
contraire cédé ça nous permettrait de
sélectionner des plantes par exemple
pouvait changer un même à même de
résister à la sécheresse
alors moi moi quand je parle de
recherche et aussi de la recherche
fondamentale c'est à dire comment on
peut imaginer des éléments qui sont en
notre connaissance aujourd'hui sur sur
des vignes sur des cépages qui sont
résistants aujourd'hui il ya des vignes
dans la drôme ou d'excédent en ardèche
où dans la drôme je sais plus il ya des
vignerons pas du tout été touchés parce
que étant plus uniquement - vu comme ça
monsieur le sénateur et en même temps de
ne pas être pour les embêter mais il
faut pas que l'art il n'y a pas une
histoire d pour des deux contres c'est
une histoire de vous représenter a
souvent été très contre ubs
mais si on parle de gmc des ogm de
culture en plein champ
non vous voulez dire je pense que
aujourd'hui il est quand même important
de donnera je pense à l'inra et je pense
à ceux ci semblent enfin des industries
et des et des organismes de recherche il
est important de leur donner des moyens
aujourd'hui vous le savez bien sûr
ministre ils vont chercher des moyens
d'une manière difficile avec des petits
contrats dans un certain nombre
d'entreprises donc ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'on puisse leur donner les moyens de
d'assurer le succès de la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique
alors c'est vrai pour l'agriculture la
viticulture c'est vrai pour
l'arboriculture
mais on peut aussi imaginer un certain
nombre puisque vous évoquez tout à
l'heure les catastrophes d'été et
notamment la sécheresse
c'est possible aussi d'avoir des
solutions qui soient beaucoup plus
résiliente que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
mais il faut que l'état investisse
lourdement auprès de la recherche jeu
mais je pars plus totalement et je
dirais il faut aussi que vous
parlementaire soyez très vigilants à ce
que le carcan législatif n'empêche pas
sous avec une certaine frilosité parce
que des débats politiques qui sont dures
n'empêche pas d'avancer
sur les nouvelles technologies qui
permettent d'identifier ces plantes
résistantes et on sait que ce débat
politiquement et reste à vous renvoyer
la balle qui l'a je vois bien que vous
renvoyer la balle à jean claude tissot
faut être pour un jeu sur ce sujet que
l'on sait pas compter sur moi je
voudrais vous à vous interpeller aussi
sur la manière dont sont gérés les
dossiers calamité de façon très précise
aujourd'hui il ya des bilans furent des
bilan fourrager qui sont faits sur place
pour la chambre d'agriculture épaulé par
la ddt par un panel d'agriculteurs sur
des et sur des exploitations reconnue
comme telle qui servent de référence
ces éléments sont transmis à vos
services à dire et souvent sont un
accueil plus ou moins mitigés ou alors
des sanctions quelquefois difficiles à
entendre quand on est sur le territoire
de moins quelques pourcents et donc qui
permettent difficilement de de pouvoir
subvenir aux besoins d'une exploitation
qui doit acheter du fourrage et c'est
donc est ce qu'on peut imaginer une
confiance de la part du service aux gens
du territoire qu'il fasse une première
chose et puis une deuxième chose aussi
il ya aussi une réglementation ou un
règlement c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
c'est les trois années glissantes donc
le fameux rapport olympio moyens dans la
pique c'est une vraie catastrophe parce
qu'au départ si on parle de deux heures
de ressources fourragères
on part de 10 tonnes de matière sèche ha
si pendant trois ans vous avez trois
années de sécheresse et bien au bout de
trois ans vous n'avez plus que calme
note de matière sèche et cc 4 temps de
jeu s'est étalé sur trois ans voilà
c'est ça et ça c'est quelque chose que
je parte alizés voilà mais on a vraiment
besoin de quelqu'un ce qui est important
ce qui est important j'entends
effectivement les remarques des uns des
autres sur la partie technique est ce
qu'on a besoin c'est après cette
catastrophe qui est une catastrophe
historique qui risque de mettre à mal
notamment les jeunes agriculteurs qui
pourront pas passer le cap
on a besoin d'un plan de solidarité
nationale extrêmement fort rapidement
sur le court terme
et puis assez rapidement quand même
derrière sur le long terme et il faut
que peut-être les départements mais
aussi les appellations puisse
s'organiser on va en parler tout à
l'heure où vais d'abord mais tout à
l'heure mais on va revenir vais d'abord
sur ce que suivait le sénateur tissot je
rende pas dans le détail technique mais
oui archives mais sympa quand même
mais oui archi oui et pour vous dire que
j'ai déjà lancé d'ailleurs la revue de
ce système de calamités agricoles parce
que on voit qu'il a des défaillances
notamment
mais connaissez mon attachement au point
notamment une défaillance agronomique
c'est à dire que ce qui est demandé aux
agriculteurs c'est le bilan fourrager
alors que la réglementation elle nous
permet d'indemniser sur la pousse entre
la pousse et le bilan fourrager la
réalité leur antre l'herbe qui a dans le
jean est ce qu ont relancé en point il
ya des fois une différents cris les
critères aujourd'hui ne sont pas les
bons gars j'ai demandé la revue de ce
système pour qu'on puisse revoir ce
système le plus rapidement j'en veux
tissot une question précise pour l'un et
pour l'autre vous voulez vous avez
évoqué les appellations d'origine
contrôlée justement vous avez une
question précise à dessus oui jean marie
sermier jean-marie excusez moi oui nous
sommes actuellement en train de
d'étudier la loi climat résilience or
l'article 1er de cette loi met en place
un écho score donc ça peut paraître
important pour que les les clients les
consommateurs puissent choisir parfait
de connaissances les produits qu'ils ont
à consommer et peut-être avoir un geste
plus citoyen simplement on s'aperçoit
que ça se passe plus difficilement sur
les problèmes sur les produits agricoles
les produits agroalimentaires à tel
point que on peut avoir des produits qui
bénéficie d'une appellation contrôlée
c'est à dire qu'ils ceux qui répondent à
un cahier des charges qui est répondent
aussi à des normes environnementales qui
font en sorte que ceux qui travaillent
essaye d'en vivre
eh bien ces produits là peuvent avoir un
écho score qui soit finalement plus
négatif que des produits d'importation
je prends un exemple tout simple un
animal une vache qui va rester pendant
trois ans dans un champ pour pouvoir
donner de la viande dans une prairie de
haute montagne
en fait elle aura son écot score qui
sera plus négatif parce que comparé à
une page qui est importé du brésil ou
l'argentine
c'était sur lequel vous aurez du maïs
ogm est donc une surface moins
importants de la police - finalement
théoriquement d'après un calcul sur pied
on nous explique qu'elle pollue moins
que la vache de monteur cette question
de jean marie services et moi alors que
vous auriez dû vous appuyez sur les
appellations d'origine contrôlée des
tigres m
une spécificité hyper france espoirs et
après mais vous avez bien vu les je vous
en remercie d'ailleurs parce que je
trouve que le débat était très équilibré
sur le sujet pour faire en sorte que les
biais méthodologiques puissent être
rectifiées avant qu'un affichage
environnemental ne soit fait dans
l'agriculture
et d'ailleurs je me souviens moi même me
faire mien l'exemple que vous avez
donnée en expliquant un certain nombre
de personnes que ce serait adhérents de
favoriser la vache importé d'argentine
par rapport à notre belle et sur les
territoires
c'est en fait l'appellation d'origine
contrôlée que ce soit les a aussi où que
ce soit pas déjà aussi la belle les
labels en général et même de manière
générale un élevage extensif
c'est-à-dire par définition peu intensif
et défavorisées alors que c'est un
élevage de nos territoires de mon par
exemple intéresse davantage par exemple
que un élevage extrêmement intensif avec
des milliers d'animaux au sud de sud fm
et rire voit cette réglementation fait
la france où c'est le roman c'est la
méthodologie utilisée qui est une
méthodologie définie en lien avec
l'ademe qui a lancé d'ores et déjà un
appareil à ce que vous pouvez de
revoyure pour s'assurer que l'affichage
environnemental ne sorte que quand ces
modifications mais ce que vous avez une
sinistre vous engagez de sortir cet
affichage environnemental à des accords
avec les professionnels de la grimace
est un sujet que j'ai identifié depuis
le premier jour en dix ans il n'est pas
possible de le faire si ça vient
fossoyer l'approchent agronomique est la
nôtre c'est à dire de favoriser nos
élevages du territoire ciat serait un
non-sens environnement en premier les
sion précise jean claude izzo
à propos des galim ma question on va en
débattre demain d'ailleurs au sénat je
vais vous interrogez un sujet là demain
après midi
force est de constater et je pense que
vous partagez mon avis c'est un échec
c'est pas une certaine réussite de celle
ci on parle si on a là si on garde le
prisme de l'agriculteur ou du paysan
c'est un échec
20 pour une fois on est d'accord c'est
bien non aujourd'hui le consommateur
paye plus cher les produits sauf que
tout la plus value n'est pas allé chez
le paysan berki à l'étal est à mon avis
plus tôt dans la distribution
ça restera à démontrer ma question est
claire comment imaginez-vous aujourd'hui
justement reprendre les propos du
président ledent sommes dans le cadre du
discours de registre fameux discours
juste une phrase donc promettait une loi
pour permettre aux agriculteurs de vivre
du juste prix payé
vous allez faire des propositions à
travers le rapport papin que je n'ai pas
encore lu juste les bonnes feuilles on
va dire comment imaginez-vous pouvoir
intervenir auprès des acheteurs pour
leur dire vous allez acheter
le prix de leurs dash le prix du veau le
prix de l'agneau tel prix tel temps vaut
au prix mais non c'est même pas tel
qu'il bossait tels que vous vous
imaginez exactement comment vous y
mettre on n'est pas dans une économie
administrée donc comment alors comment
allez vous y prendrez alors de façon
très claire alors très clair mais je
vais le cil de faire une relation
commerciale dans l'agroalimentaire ces
trois personnes l'éleveur l'industriel
la grande distribution
on est toujours le même jeu de dupes
c'est à dire que l'éleveur demande à la
grande distribution d'augmenter le prix
d'achat et la grande distribution dit à
l'éleveur moi je voulais bien mais
j'avais peur que l'industriel ne vous
rétrocède pas l'augmentation donc je
n'ai pas fait et l'éleveur se tourner
vers les industriels et l'industriel dis
moi j'ai demandé à la grande
distribution il n'a pas voulu faire même
jeudi
comment on fait pour sortir de jeu de
dupes et galim a dit une chose
fondamentale et lille faut faire la
marche en avant ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que l'industriel ne peut aller
discuter avec la grande distribution que
s'il a discuté avant avec l'éleveur sauf
que le manquement des galim c'est qu'il
a simplement dit la méthode il n'a pas
fixé suffisamment les règles du jeu et
donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est aller sur
les règles du jeu plus de contraintes
beaucoup plus drastiques
et c'est quoi c'est de faire une
contractualisation à 3 alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
donc vous n'avez pas une répartition
faut faire de la transparence des marges
sur les trois oui mais vont faire défini
pour faire de la pluriannualité et se
pose même une question qui moi ma faveur
c'est dire une fois que l'industriel et
l'agriculteur se sont mis d'accord sur
un prix il faut fixer ce prix et faire
en sorte que ce prix ne soient plus
négociable ensuite que ça s'impose à la
grande distribution qui consiste à
revenir sur noye que monsieur député
cernier connais bien qui la loi elle est
me de 2007 2008 qui en fait était une
loi qui a consisté à dire on augmente le
pouvoir d'achat des français sur le dos
des agriculteurs en faisant baisser les
prix je pense que politiquement c'est
facile mais c'est une erreur oui mais
sauf que c'est un but puis parce que
demain si monsieur carrefour monsieur
auchan monsieur leclerc pas voir un
paysan et lui dis-je
je n'achète votre produit tel prix s'il
n'est pas d'accord il fait quoi
il va ailleurs n'ont alors rien ne va
l'un d'eux lui imposera d'acheter au
prix qu'on va lui il indiqué oui
maintenant le train d'abord ça se passe
pas comme ça ça se passe dans ces
contractualisation à 3 alors après on
peut imaginer des 4 millions mais ça se
passe pas comme ça deuxièmement dans on
pourrait aller dans le fond des détails
de ce qu'on recommande avec serge papin
mais c'est qu'il ya en plus la création
d'une institution de règlement des
différends qui permet d'avoir cet organe
de contrôle qui sort de l'affrontement
frontal entre les uns et les autres donc
c'est tout cet équilibre qu'on met en
place
après si votre question c'est dire il
faut administrer les prix j'ai pas dit
ça je voyais la question mais
l'administration des prix dans une
exempt cadre et une économie administrée
c'est ça n'est pas possible et cher
content de dire que quand vous êtes mis
d'accord sur un prix ce prix ne doit
plus être négocié ça ce serait un
changement énorme
c'est vraiment pour moi le moment de
bascule c'est la loi lme parce que la
loi lme a dit on arrête on remet la
négociabilité tout au long de la chaîne
histoire la défense vous avez bien que
c'est pas compliqué que ça et que
notamment dans la grande distribution
vous avez un certain nombre de charges à
l'adresse des entreprises
agroalimentaires ou des producteurs qui
sont payés par eux pour permettre
d'avoir leurs produits notamment
référence aux lire ligne référencées et
les réalités et c'est ça pose un vrai
souci mais c'est ça qui a fait la loi
elles mêmes justement en se disant on
arrête les marges arrière et on fait un
système qui consiste à des marges
arrière était encore pire
sauf que elle se faisait pas sur le dos
des agriculteurs bien on va faire un
détournement par le figaro live où nous
attend vincent robes en soie sans vous
allez nous dire vincent ce que les
internautes vos lecteurs nos
téléspectateurs ont retenu abbas qui
marque beaucoup les internautes ces
dernières heures notamment c'est la
réouverture partielle des pubs et des
restaurants en grande bretagne après
quatre mois de fermeture alors une
question pour vous je viens de normandie
est ce que on peut toujours croire à la
promesse d' emmanuel macron d'une
réouverture mis mes questions
subsidiaires
est ce que le secteur est ce que vous
jugez que le secteur est vitale pour les
agriculteurs
c'est un secteur qui est immensément
important pour un certain type de
produits la viticulture mais tant
d'autres vous savez il ya des
un certain nombre vous prenez la filière
de la viande par exemple il s'avère que
le veau on en mange beaucoup plus dans
les restaurants que dans les
supermarchés
donc il ya beaucoup de secteurs comme ça
qui sont incroyablement pénalisé qui
fait qu'on a mis des mesures de soutien
après la question de la réouverture on
le souhaite tous mais tous infiniment je
veux dire ce serait une libération
le jour où on pourra retourner en
terrasse et ça ça dépend d'une seule
chose aujourd'hui c'est la vaccination
d'une deuxième chose qui est la
vaccination d'une troisième chose qui
est la vaccination est donc notre
objectif c'est d'accélérer cette
vaccination et c'est ce qu'on fait avec
le ledit milieu d'eux mêmes français qui
a été vaccinée avec le la production de
doses de vaccins l'intention de notre
territoire et la montée en puissance de
ses vassaux formation est ce que ça veut
dire que l'objectif de mime et pourrait
ne pas être tenue
moi je me fie au calendrier défini par
le par le président de la république ce
dont je suis sûr c'est que pour tenir ce
calendrier c'est toute la montée en
puissance de de la vaccination et que
les énergies de toutes et tous tout
responsable politique quel qu'il soit
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir les yeux rivés
sur la courbe de la vaccination
plus que des élections si je puis dire
ah ça c'est autre chose ne va pas
relancer le débat
merci vincent merci vincent et merci
aussi aux parlementaires qui vous qui
ont débattu avec vous ce soir jean marie
sermier et j'ai plus de tissot merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau
merci à vous julien de normandie par
accepter d'interprétation dans audition
publique nous avoir apporté aussi des
moments d'éclairage et et quelques
informations précises notamment sur les
aides qui vont être débloqués pour les
agriculteurs sinistrés
c'est la fin d'audition publique que
vous pourrez retrouver vie aussi
évidemment sur le figaro live bonne
soirée merci à bientôt
[Musique]